what I want to do in this video is give
an overview of the endomembrane system
in eukaryotic cells endo endo membrane
system and at a very high level the
endomembrane system is all of the the
membranes that interact with each other
inside of a cell so what membranes are
we talking about well you could start
off by talking about the cell membrane
itself and all of these membranes these
have by layers of phospholipids I
sometimes my brain malfunctions and I
call them by lipid layers but these are
by layers of phospholipids so if I were
to zoom in right over here if I were to
zoom in right over there that line it
really is a bilayer a bilayer of
phospholipids so it would look like this
so you have your hydro hydrophilic heads
pointing outwards and your hydrophobic
tails pointing inwards so hydrophilic
heads pointing outwards hydrophobic
tails pointing inwards and it keeps
going so you have if we think of it from
left to right you have a layer of - or
you have a bilayer I should say of
phospholipids that's going to be true
with a cellular membrane that's going to
be true of this of the outer nuclear
membrane right over here we drew this
one on the video on the endoplasmic
reticulum and so over here you see these
two membranes you might say okay is this
a bilayer no this is actually two
bilayers so this membrane right over
here is has a phospholipid bilayer and
this membrane over here also has a
phospholipid by a phospholipid bilayer
this the one
let me just in another color this one
that I'm starting to starting to trace
in magenta that's the outer membrane of
the nuclear envelope and it's continuous
it's continuous with the membrane of the
endoplasmic reticulum which I'm starting
to highlight right over here and then
the one that I'm highlighting in this
purple color in this purple color this
is the inner membrane of the nuclear
envelope and all of this is part of the
endomembrane system so I already just
I've already started talking about the
endoplasmic reticulum and we go into
some depth on that
the video on the endoplasmic reticulum
and the Golgi apparatus but it's also
part of the endomembrane system and in
the endoplasmic reticulum in particular
can represent up to or even more than
50% of the membrane associated the
phospholipid membrane associated with
the cell and we've talked about what
goes on in the lumen of the endoplasmic
reticulum so this area right over here
right over here we've talked about what
happens there
proteins can get synthesized actually
other molecules like lipids can get
synthesized there they can and then they
can go to the smooth ER and then the
place where they can exit from the
smooth ER and we saw that in the video
on the endoplasmic reticulum how they
can kind of butt out we call this area
it's often called the transitional ER so
this area right over here we would call
the transitional endoplasmic reticulum
transitional transitional transitional
transitional ER is this place where
these proteins are being butted off and
they're budding off in vesicles so this
is the transitional ER and all vesicles
are are little small compartments that
have a membrane around it that things
like a protein can be transported in and
not you know I don't want to beat a dead
horse here but all of these lines that
I'm drawing even though I drew it as a
single line
these are phospholipid bilayers so the
membrane might be different the
phospholipid bilayers might be different
when we go from one piece of the
membrane to another but they all have
that same general notion of having this
this bilayer of phospholipids but just
as a review these proteins they can they
can they can emerge from the
transitional ER they can make their way
to the golgi apparatus and we've already
talked about how in the Golgi apparatus
these these proteins can be matured and
when I say being matured there's a bunch
of enzymes in here there's a bunch of
Golgi enzymes in here that can do all
sorts of things to the proteins tag them
they can actually they can actually add
add add saccharides to them so that they
become glycoproteins they can tag them
so they can be used in the cellular
membrane or be used outside of the
cellular membrane
we used other places in the cell so for
example this protein right over here
butted off as a vesicle it makes its way
to the Golgi apparatus the membrane can
then merge and dump the protein into the
Golgi apparatus from there it can be
matured it may might turn into a
glycoprotein who knows what happens to
it and then it could butt off again and
then this protein that's now butted off
it could go to be embedded into the
cellular membrane the protein could be
excreted from the cell or it could go to
other parts of the cell now those aren't
everything I've just talked about those
aren't the only parts of the
endomembrane system you have things like
vacuoles which are membrane bound
organelles in a Cell in plant cells a
vacuole can be used for storage it could
be used for structure vacuoles can get
quite large and they can actually give
kind of the structure of the actual
plant in animal cells in animal cells
you might have something called a
lysosome and a lysosome is a membrane
brown structure where essentially things
go to for the most part be be recycled
or to be to be torn apart so you know
maybe something got packaged from
someplace this is some molecules over
let me do this in another color you have
some and I drew that vesicle a little
bit too big but maybe this stuff it
needs to be destroyed so this membrane
is going to it can then merge with that
membrane and dump its contents and then
dump its contents in here and this has a
very low this has a low pH and it can
actually kind of break apart this stuff
and it can digest this stuff and recycle
in it into it's kind of I guess you
could say more constituent material so
all of this is part of the endomembrane
system so once again whole figures you
an appreciation for how complex and and
a lot of levels beautiful cells can be